[Music]
in America we tend to think that the
news is all about us all the time at
some level you really can't blame us
though just turn on CNN or Fox News or
MSNBC and all you get these days is
endless election coverage with like a
tiny bit of national news and maybe a
minute and hour on the international
front occasionally when something big
flares up the Talking Heads will focus
on Syria or North Korea or Iran for a
couple days but then it's quickly back
to the usual grind even when something
huge like drags it is happening we
barely talk about it in the US until the
very last second when suddenly every
pundit who hasn't mentioned it once in
the past year is supposedly an expert
beyond hearing about terror attacks we
barely even talk about the countries we
have the most in common with once the
initial response to the attack is over
has anything happened in the UK since
brexit what's been happening in France
since the Paris attacks
how are the tapas in Spain or the pasta
in Italy or the cheese in Denmark you
might know and I might know but I bet
it's from alternative news sources and
social media and not from mainstream
television the danger of only hearing
about other countries when bad things
happen like terror attacks riots and
scandals is that you begin to think
that's all that there is to these other
places as well as the citizens that live
there themselves imagine if other
countries only associated Americans with
our current election menu already do and
that is pretty shitty although possibly
warranted every country on Earth every
single one has elements in it that are
good and that are bad this doesn't mean
that every country or every culture is
equal this is not the case but every
country is made up of all sorts of
people with all sorts of beliefs as I've
said often on this show the ultimate
minority is the individual judging an
entire group as a collective will almost
always assure you dismiss huge amounts
of people who don't fit the stereotype
or the narrative I've said this before
and I'll say it again one of the things
that I'm most proud of about the Rubin
report is that our audience is truly
worldwide when we did our fan show a
couple months ago we got messages from
people in over 60
country's we chose people based on their
individual attributes not because we
expected them to represent an entire
nation while our mainstream media does a
pretty poor job of showing that we have
more in common than what separates us I
find that people like you the ones
watching this right now do an incredibly
good job of it the conversations I see
you having in the comment sections right
here on Twitter and on Facebook or even
on your own YouTube videos are
connecting people from all over the
world I see you guys constantly trying
to cut through the nonsense and have
real conversations and find some common
ground together is the only way that
we'll have a chance to truly be heard my
guest this week is Australian journalist
Rita Panahi Rita grew up in Iran in a
Muslim family and emigrated to Australia
when she was 6 years old she's now a
fierce defender of Western values and
spends much of her time writing about
the same issues I talk about on the show
we're going to talk about her childhood
in Iran as well as her life in Australia
is there more to that giant island
country than just boomerangs and
kangaroos I suspect there might just be
to prove my earlier point when was the
last time you heard anything in the news
about Australia since the terrorist
attack in Sydney almost two years ago
they had a nationwide election about two
months ago but I think I only heard
about that because of a random link on
Twitter if you're watching this you're
you've already shed much of the
mainstream nonsense but our work is
still cut out for us let's keep talking
to interesting people from all over the
world and if you've got suggestions well
there's a comment section right down
below
[Music]
you
[Music]